I was about to give you a compliment to Steve.
I was about to go give you a really good I'll get, do it anyway.
Let me change face. Let me change the face. Okay.
It's so crazy. It's so creepy.
Another thing that I love about you, and this is, and you just take it,
just take it. Okay. Is, you know, stand up.
Comedy is something I started with in 1995.
I signed up for open mic. I'd never done anything before acting nothing.
I just walked off the streets and signed up at a open mic in San Diego.
And, um, I started doing it. I worked really,
I went up every night bobbed for years and I got to
a point moved to LA and I did all the Riggleman roll and all the things that you
need to do. And I got to a place where, Oh, I can audition for shows now.
And I got on the tonight show and I did all the things, right. And so, you know,
I feel like I am a organic, you know, stand up
and, you know, as comics, when we talk, right,
we see actors and other people from other fields, right. Crossover,
and do stand up. Right.
And it takes a lot for us to go,
to give that person its rightful credit and go that person's a
standup now because I know thousands of people that actors and other people that
have crossed over and I went, that guy. That guy should not be doing it,
but you're the type of standup that you should be doing it because you proved
your worth. Well, thanks man.
I'll tell you why I say that it was one night you were at the store or whatever.
You're talking with a bunch of comics. You were hanging out when,
in my head I thought it didn't. I was never,
it was not a question that you shouldn't be there.
You know? I mean, like I looked at you,
like I looked at Whitney Cummings or any of these other people like, Oh cool.
Steve was here, my friend, you know, like a comic. Right. You know, you know,
a long time ago when I saw your staple,
your at the mint right back in the day. Right. I wouldn't even fathom that.
I would even accept that. Like there's a rare case.
You are like that obviously Theo Vaughn, cause the avant didn't come from,
you know, um,
a standup he had to change or he had to reinvent
himself. Right. And you did.
And I knew this also when you invited me and Ian over to your house,
because you were working on your first special to give you notes. And again,
you and I, and I still talk about it, how we respected that,
that you wanted our, you know, notes and your help with your special.
It was like, you know, um, I just, you know, my hats off to you,
you know, I wasn't,
I was going to see this earlier on the podcast then you attacked me about,
and I literally thought to myself,
I'm not going to even going to this for this face.
Then I just decided to do it anyway, because I really do mean that, man.
How do you feel about it?
I, I, why I super love you. I super appreciate your kind words.
I really, really do.
I love that you were willing to come over to check out this.
And if I recall correctly, it was like,
I think it was like a week or two weeks before I was actually going to tape the
special. Yeah. And I had you guys come over, I asked you to come over to, uh,
to view like the, the last show I had taped, you know, Oh, what should I do?
And you were like, Hey man, maybe next time one on ship.
Let's do this a little sooner when it's not like next week. Like,
and, and I also remembered too that, uh, I mean,
you'd been very kind because I wasn't ready to take.
That's special.
Like you wish you hadn't done it. It wasn't that I wished that I hadn't done it.
It was just that, you know, like there were, there was just,
there was a lot that they just, you know,
I mean for where I was at that time, it couldn't have come out any better.
But where I was at that time was very early in the process and here's something
that I had a lot. I have a lot.